alright alright alright let's talk
business and I only talk business in my
business barn the thing about me is I'm
a straight shooter
and I only do business with other
strikes shaders oh I assure you we all
shoot straight here don't we well I'm
gonna need you to prove it not a problem
is there a target the target is this
really glass oh you got a do shoot it
off the tippy-top and my Butler's head
one shot each idiot
[Music]
what are you gonna do I missed on
purpose
[Music]
shrimpie shooting guns at Butler's just
because my coworkers are it's 2019
[Music]
at her it's not a scarecrow unfamiliar
done if I had a second shot I totally
would have hit it looks like you could
use some help there pretty bad yeah tell
you how to do is hockey Oh squeeze the
trigger straight shooters after all
looks like we're in business had to be
done he was whore it was alright when he
kissed my houseguest but my business
partners uh-oh
no ma'am now we're gonna play another
little game a little game I like to call
bury the bother